bootle cat podcast
hey go watch uh me and this guy's full
interview out right now man but you know
I'd say he's one of my favorite rappers
we got to get into it man that Mexican
OT thank you thank you thank you dog
thank you for having me new album comes
out the 28th or 27th July 28th 28th yes
sir let's get to it man let's get to it
oh my goodness scales you rocking baby
look
look I like that one TV on the drums
scales on the loop
we gonna let this footballs run by come
on
yeah
hola
look
oh
[Music]
you already know boom I appreciate you
guys watching this freestyle we got
another one coming and then another one
and then another one and they're all
brought to you by our good Folks at LRG
clothing you already know what it is LRG
been keeping you fly for years they got
so much new fly gear right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30 off
l-r-g.com another freestyle's on the way
presented by LRG